-Well, thank you, Judy, for
that very generous introduction.
And thanks very much to
the Radcliffe Institute
for giving me the opportunity
to spend the year here.
It's been just
rejuvenating to be
here amongst so many
diverse scholars and artists
and writers all pursuing their
projects with such energy.
So today, I want to tell you
about my work here, which
is as Judy was saying,
a new direction for me,
applying polymer
physics and theory
to try to help in a larger
project, which is to develop
new polymers for solar power.
The original title of my talk
was some very complicated
thing.
And it should have been this.
And there should be a
question mark at the end
here since this is prospective.
These materials are
not, by any means,
commercial yet, as you'll see.
Where I'm normally
located is Penn State.
This is our iconic Old Main
viewed across Old Main Lawn.
So the outline of
my talk, I'll begin
with a summary, an
introduction of current trends
in solar power,
present technology,
how it's being
applied, and give you
a status report on where we
are in terms of solar power
being an important contributor
to power in the world.
I'll then talk about how
solar cells work, briefly,
and I hope in an
understandable way,
in order to motivate
how one might develop
a new kind of material
different from what we use now
for making solar cells and
why we might want to do that.
And then how we might do
it, how we would think
about designing those polymers.
And I've used the word
polymers about six times.
And Judy neatly introduced
them as long-chain molecules.
And trust me, I'll tell you
with pictures what they are
and why they might be
useful for this purpose.
And then I'll talk
about how theorist
can help in this project.
I'm a theoretical
physicist, but not
the sort that you
think of when you think
of a theoretical physicist.
I don't work on the early
universe or black holes
or supernovas or
superconductors or absolute zero
or quantum entanglement
or anything like that,
but just mundane properties
of solids and liquids
and where those properties come
from and how to design them in,
so how theorists can
help in this project.
And then, at the very
end, I'll give an example
that illustrates a
style of our thinking,
how a theorist might
work on this problem.
So it tunnels from the
large to the particular.
So arguably, the greatest
technological challenge
of the century is finding
replacements for fossil fuels.
Fossil fuels have been an
incredible boon to humankind.
They made the Industrial
Revolution possible.
They are indispensable in modern
life and developed nations.
And yet, it's time, and
in fact, really past time
to begin to bid them goodbye.
And the reason for that
as you're all quite aware
is climate change,
global warming.
And over the past two
centuries roughly,
since the start of the second
Industrial Revolution powered
by burning fossil
fuels, we've been
returning carbon
that was deposited
over hundreds of millions
of years in two centuries
into the atmosphere.
And as a result, CO2
levels in the atmosphere
have steadily risen.
And that has led to the
planet steadily warming.
You can draw a line, more
or less, through this data,
and particularly, post-war
with more and more growth
of fossil fuel
use, and this trend
is playing havoc with climate.
And so that is the most pressing
reason, not the only reason,
for wanting to
replace fossil fuels.
Now this isn't going to be easy.
Fossil fuels, oil,
natural gas, and coal,
are uniquely convenient
sources of chemical energy.
They are useful for
transportation fuels,
for powering power plants
to make electricity,
for doing chemistry, all
the petrochemicals industry
is based on this stuff,
for doing metallurgy,
for smelting metals from ores.
And it won't be one
thing that replaces them.
So here's a list, all of
which you've heard of,
of things which can
replace certain functions
of fossil fuels in
contemporary advanced nations.
And these fuels will
continue to play a role,
I think, for a long, long time,
especially for petrochemicals
and for transportation
because they're just
so convenient for carrying
around a lot of power
in a small place.
I mean, for flying
planes, for instance,
it's really hard
to imagine how you
could do that other
than with chemical fuel.
You could make that
fuel with biofuels,
but you're going to need
those kinds of liquids
into the indefinite future.
Here are many
sources each of which
can play a role in
replacing these, efficiency,
LED lighting and more
efficiently insulated homes
and things, can be thought of
as a source of energy and one
that we really need to exploit.
Geothermal, particularly
for heating.
Every heat pump is a cheap way
of pumping heat from someplace
into your house.
And the cheapest place to
get warmth in the winter
is actually deep in the
ground, not very deep, 10s
of feet in the ground.
And that's something we should
be exploiting universally.
Hydroelectric power is
clearly an attractive non
global warming form of
power, but this is not
something easily expanded
because we've basically
dammed all of the rivers
that makes sense to dam.
And we've learned over decades
about the environmental
consequences of doing that.
It's not something you're going
to see a lot of growth in.
Nuclear power.
This is going to be an
increasingly important source
of electricity as global warming
is more intensively addressed.
Currently, in the US, something
like 20% of our electricity
comes from nuclear power,
just as a benchmark.
And then solar and
wind, about which
there's been a great
deal of excitement
in the past five or 10 years,
but certainly in the past five
years.
So this talk will focus
primarily on solar.
But you should bear
in mind that it's
one component of a large
slate of replacements.
So where are we in
this process now?
So if you look worldwide at the
amount of non global warming
energy and where
it comes from, you
find out that basically it comes
in more or less equal shares
from hydro and nuclear power.
With solar and wind
just a tiny fraction.
And all of this is
only 12% of the total.
This is total energy
not total electricity.
And that shows you the
scale of a challenge,
to grow this into something
that's big on this scale.
OK.
There are two different ways
of getting power from the sun.
One way is to use
a bunch of mirrors
to focus sunlight onto a single
place, the top of this tower
here, that you
use to boil water,
make steam, drive a
turbine and a generator,
much as you would in any kind
of electric power generation
plant.
And this is a good idea
in places where sunlight
is strong and continuous,
so the desert,
North Africa, the American
southwest, someplace like that.
And this is photovoltaic or
what I'll call, solar electric,
it's a direct
conversion of sunlight
to electricity using those shiny
little blue panels that you
know.
This is a large installation
recently open in the UK.
So that's what I'm going
to be talking about
for the rest of
the talk, progress
in installing solar electric.
To get an idea about the
progress that we've made,
it's useful to know
where electricity
is being consumed in the world.
So this pie chart here gives
you the headline story.
China, the US, the EU, and
Japan, account for about 3/4
of the electricity
use in the world.
And so it makes the most sense
to ask what those nations
and regions are doing in terms
of installing and developing
solar electric.
And here's a bar
chart that shows that.
What's the percentage of
electricity in those places
currently produced
by solar electric?
China and the US
are still needing
to make a lot of progress
around a percent each.
The EU and Japan substantially
further along, around 5%.
And Germany, if you were to
separate that out from the EU,
is still further
along with something
like 10% of
electricity from solar,
about equivalent to
nuclear power in Germany.
And this-- not because the
sun shines all the time
in Germany but because
of serious political will
to do it.
And also because the cost
of electricity in the EU
is something like 1.5
to 3 times as much
as it is, for
example, in the US.
So this is where we are.
It's important then
to ask how fast
the installation of current
solar technology is growing.
This is a graph showing you
how much new capacity is
being installed each year.
And you can see,
basically it's increasing
by 10, of whatever this
unit is, every year.
The amount installed
is growing linearly.
And so if you're trying to
make an estimate of how long it
would be before you were really
serious about solar electric,
if we're at 2% now in the
world, how long would it
take to get to 20%?
One thing you could do would
be to extrapolate that,
say that the rate of
increase of inflation
was going to keep
going, and then
to figure out how long
it would take to install
enough to get to 30%-- 20%.
And the answer is
about 30 years.
OK.
So that's a way of measuring
the size of the challenge.
When something's
growing that fast,
sometimes it makes sense
to plot it on a log scale.
So for those of you who don't
speak log, this kind of a graph
is a special one in which
each increment this way
is a factor of 10.
So that's just a funny
way of plotting things.
And a line that's
straight on this plot
is what we call exponential
growth, like every 10
years it goes up by a factor
of 2 or a factor of 10
or whatever.
And you can see
that roughly that's
what's going on in terms of
the growth of solar electric.
And so this is 2%
in the world now,
and how long would it take to
get 10 times bigger than that?
That's one of these increments.
And so I just draw a
little line through here,
and that's like a decade.
So predictions are hard,
especially about the future,
as Yogi Berra said.
But somewhere between
10 and 30 years
is maybe reasonable, unless
other things intervene,
where the world will have
installed a serious amount
of solar electric capacity.
OK.
So the current technology that's
being installed on rooftops
and farmers' fields
and so on, is
those blue, shiny blue
solar panels that you know,
is based on silicon,
the element silicon.
And they're made in
great big plants.
Silicon, basically
the same stuff
that computer chips
are made out of.
And in fact, the material's
not that different
that what computer
chips are made out of.
But it's a pretty involved
process to make that stuff.
It involves clean rooms
and bunny suits and robots.
And then, eventually,
you get panels
that you can install some place.
At the heart of it all is
the metal-- well, actually
semiconductor-- but anyway,
shiny, metally looking stuff,
silicon, which is very
carefully refined, very
carefully crystallized.
You have the smelt it and
melt it and do all this stuff
and then slice it
into little disks
and assemble it
into these cells.
And it's a quite
involved process.
Nonetheless, prices have
been steadily falling.
OK.
And this is as a result of
just slow, steady engineering
improvements,
improvements of scale,
of building bigger
plants, of just learning
how to do it more
cheaply and better,
the making of these cells.
And the prices have
fallen to the point
that-- of course, it costs
more if you're a person
to install this on your
roof than if you're
a utility installing
it at huge scale.
But if you take these
prices and figure out
how long, in terms of the
cost of electricity, would
it take to pay back
the investment,
then the answer is, if you're
a residential customer,
it's like 20 years.
This is without subsidy.
This is at the price of $0.10
a kilowatt hour that we all
on average pay in the US.
And 10 years if
you're a utility.
And that's, as I
say, without subsidy.
I mean, that's not a
financial estimate,
but you see that you're
getting to the place
where these things
are cheap enough
to really be competitive.
And that's the origin of
the current excitement
in installing them on
a much larger scale.
And so then the
politics of it matters.
And it matters whether you
do or don't have subsidies,
and whether utility companies do
or don't finagle the system so
that it's somehow less
advantageous than it
used to be to install them
on your roof and so on.
These politics really
matter now because it's
at a place where the
installation is really--
can be competitive.
And the situation
should improve.
And you can see that if the
price of electricity, as it
is in the UK, was one and
a half to three times more,
you see that this is
really quite attractive.
OK.
So when you're talking
about growing something
another factor of 10, you might
wonder what other things might
intervene to make
that difficult.
And there's a variety of
things that might intervene.
A silly question
you might ask-- I
just bring this
up because I just
was trolling the internet
looking for all kinds of things
about this and there was
this, how much area would
it need on the world to power
the world in solar electricity
like 100%.
OK.
Well, it's a silly
question because the world
is a big place.
I mean, really big compared
to the area of cities.
So you can hardly even see it.
But that little square
in Nevada and this piece
here, they've picked the
parts which are really sunny.
It's not a big
area in the world.
This is not a problem.
Of course that's not-- I
mean, if you installed it
that way, you'd have to ask,
what happens when the sun goes
down and how do I get the
electricity from Nevada
to the places it needs to be.
And obviously, there
are huge challenges
the more you rely only
on solar electric.
And I'm not going to
say anymore about that.
A different, slightly
more practical way
of asking this
question is how much
area of solar panels at the
current efficiency, the kind
that you go into Lowe's
or Home Depot and buy now,
how much area would you
need per person to supply
all the electricity in the US?
And so, of course, the natural
measure of area in the US
is a football field.
So you want to know how
much of a football field
each person would need.
And it's like that much, 40
square feet or something.
And if you think about
that in terms of rooftops,
it means that if solar energy,
solar electric were really
going to be commonplace, every
neighborhood you went in you'd
be looking on roofs and
you'd be seeing these things.
That's the-- and
that's another measure
of the scale of the challenge.
They would have to be installed
in that commonplace of fashion
to be big contributors
to electric power.
OK.
So that's the summary
of where we are
with the current technology.
A different subject
that I now turn to
is what sort of possibly
displaces materials
are there that could be used in
place of the shiny blue stuff
that is currently used.
And people have been
working like crazy on this.
We're not going to go through
every one of these curves.
Each one of these
lines represents
some kind of material.
And all those little words
there are different labs
that have made records in how
efficient a cell they make.
This graph is
efficiency versus year.
So efficiency means how
much of the sunlight
shining on the cell gets
turned into useful electricity?
And out of this
forest of graphs I
want to make a
couple of remarks.
First this middle part,
the blue ones, those
are the tried and true
materials, that's silicon.
OK.
That's the stuff that's
currently being installed.
And the current efficiency
of those things-- and you
can see this is not
going up very fast.
People have been working
very patiently on this
for 40, 50 years.
And it's hard.
It's around 20%.
So 20% of the sunlight
that shines on the thing
gets turned into electricity.
These ones up here,
those purple ones,
are efficient but quite
expensive, and not likely
to be competitive with
this because of that ever.
But they're great if you're
putting up a satellite
or if you're the
Defense Department
or if you're sending
off a deep space probe
and you want to have something
that very efficiently collects
sunlight.
Because efficient
would mean smaller area
for the same amount
of electricity.
It's just that these
are really expensive.
And then there's this little
innocuous little orange bunch
down here, which have
only really started
being looked at in the past
decade or so, new materials.
And these ones are
different from those
in a qualitative way.
These things are
all-- to your eye
they would look like metals.
They're hard materials.
They're crystals.
They're brittle.
To produce them
involves smelting
things in high temperatures
and stuff like that.
These are chemicals.
These are molecules.
They're made by chemists
not by metallurgist.
They come from chemistry and
polymer chemistry and stuff
not from solid state physics.
And so what I want
to transition now
to talk about is what
are these new materials,
why are they
potentially interesting,
and what advantages
might they possibly have?
OK.
So these materials come-- the
polymer versions of them--
come from polymer chemistry.
OK.
So I still haven't told
you what a polymer is,
but Judy already did that.
And I promise next slide
that I'll tell you.
Anyway, the point
is, they're not
made in these big factory
clean room things,
they're made in a continuous
way in chemical plants.
And they're made, well,
cheaply because polymers are
things like plastics and stuff.
And those materials
are not expensive.
And so these processes
very efficiently
convert chemical raw
materials into polymers.
And the nice thing
about them is twofold.
One, polymer chemists
have gotten really good
at designing different polymers
to have different properties
and do different stuff.
And two, they're very easily
processed into different things
that you want, like fibers
and films and stuff like that.
And so the vision, or the
hallucination or something,
is that you could
make a polymer that
would have the magical property
that when you shine light on it
electricity comes out.
And then that you could
make it into solar cells
by extruding it and printing
on and things like that.
Of that practical end of
things, I will say no more.
What I'm going to
focus on now is
what are these special
polymers and how on earth
could they do that?
So what's a polymer?
It's like Judy said,
a long chain molecule.
So here is the very simplest
polymer, polyethylene.
It's a chain of carbons
with hydrogens hanging off.
This isn't a very long one.
Imagine one that was like
hundreds of carbons long.
OK.
Sometimes we like to draw
those with little balls
and sticks to give more of an
idea about where the atoms are.
This one's straight.
But a thing about
these molecules
is that they're flexible.
Between these sticks you
can rotate them around.
And so it can make a very
twisty shape as well as
a straight shape.
And so it means that
just writing down
the sequence of the atoms, or
the monomers is the fancy word,
or beads, you might say,
the repeating units, beads,
like beads on a string, writing
down what beads they are
isn't the end of the story
for how the material behaves.
You need to know whether the
chains are maybe all lined up
like spaghetti immediately
out of the box,
or whether they are more
all tangled and twisted up
like spaghetti after you cook
it, or somehow in between.
And it matters hugely what
the properties of the material
are between one and the other.
So polymers you know.
Every one of you speaks polymers
and uses them every day.
Latex paint, the stuff
that-- not the color part
but everything else--
that makes the film
on the wall, that's a polymer.
Polycarbonate that
DVDs are made out of.
Polyvinyl chloride,
PVC plastic wrap
for food, polypropylene
for fibers and jackets,
PET that all Coke bottles
and things are made out of,
nylons, rubber tires, Kevlar
and bulletproof vests.
There's two different
kinds of polymer
in diapers, the
kind that absorbs
and the kind that
holds it all in.
And what makes
them all different
are the beads that
are strung together
by the polymer chemist.
They're all long
chain molecules.
But they're chains
of different beads.
And it's a very long story about
where all these properties come
from and why these
fibers are soft
and why these polymers
and they're absorbent
and why these ones let just
the right amount of moisture
go through and all that stuff.
It depends on the
translation from these beads,
these chemical repeats,
so the material
properties of the whole stuff.
And that's the job of polymer
material science to figure out.
OK.
So to talk about how you
would design a polymer to do
the job of a solar
cell, you need
to say a little about
how solar cells work.
OK.
So solar cells convert
sunlight to electricity.
Sunlight comes in little
individual indivisible packets
called photons.
And so photons come in as
the sunlight is impinging
on the little blue stuff.
And a little blue stuff is a
thin film of silicon material.
And the sunlight gets absorbed--
the photons get absorbed.
And each time a
photon gets absorbed,
it makes something
called an exciton.
I'm going to explain
what that is in a minute.
But right now, you
can think of it
as just a little close pair of
a positive and negative charge.
And this film of
solar cell stuff
is actually two films together.
One film tends to pull
the electrons toward it.
And the other one tends
to pull the-- sorry,
the negative charges.
And the other one tends to
pull the positive charges.
So the exciton if it
wonders to this interface
can separate there.
And if it separates,
then it would pile up
the negative charges on one
side and the positive charges.
But remember, opposite
charges attract.
They'd like to get
back together again.
So if you give them
a wire out the top
of the thing
through a light bulb
and down to the
bottom of the thing,
they can get back together again
by going around the other way.
OK.
And that's how the thing makes
electricity, roughly speaking.
Here's a close up
of the same thing.
The photon comes in,
makes this exciton--
about which I'll say
more in a minute--
somehow it separates into
charges which could gather it
up by electrodes, by conductors
on the top and bottom, special
conductors that you can see
through because the light has
to get in.
And then you've gather
it up and use it
to do useful electrical work.
So I want to say more
about the electrons,
the positive charges,
and the excitons.
So now we're getting into
the most technical part
of the discussion--
no equations though.
Well actually there's
one-- keep your eye
peeled for the equation
that comes late in the talk.
There's one that slipped in.
So I want to give you a
little cartoon about what
it looks like inside silicon.
This is not a very accurate
cartoon but it's good enough.
So silicon is made of atoms.
Atoms have a nucleus, which
is positively charged.
It's a heavy thing.
It's where all the mass of the
silicon comes from basically.
It's heavy.
It's very point like.
And they're arranged
in a regular array,
sort of like a
stack of cannonballs
but not touching exactly.
So suppose we then assemble
a crystal of silicon
by first putting down
the nuclei, which
are all positively
charged, like I said.
Then I'm going to
start adding electrons.
Electrons are just the opposite.
They're negatively charged.
They're light.
And they're fluttery.
They don't stay in
one place very well.
They sort of make a cloud.
This is quantum mechanics
and I'm just trying
to give you a feel for it.
Anyway, the very
first electrons I
add see these positive charges
and hover tightly around them.
Those are very tightly bound
because they're close and very
strongly attracted.
And then I add some more.
I haven't yet added enough
to cancel all the charges.
Those ones are less well bound.
You add some more,
less well bound.
The very last ones you add
are having a little trouble
finding a good
place to be and they
sit joining the
different atoms together.
And that makes bonds that
holds the silicon together.
And those are the most
weakly bound electrons
in the whole thing.
And now it's neutral
because I added back
just the right amount of charge.
And all the equal
and opposite charges
are more or less happy
in a chunk of material.
OK.
And now, I add an
extra electron.
Where did it come from?
I don't know, I just
put it in there.
And it needs to
find a place to go.
And so there's not
any very good places.
But there's the best
available place.
And so it looks maybe like that.
There's other
equally good places.
And so with certain kinds
of materials, and silicon
is an example,
that extra electron
can pretty easily go from
one place to another.
And when it does,
that current flowing.
That's a negative
charge moving around.
So you might wonder well how
does the positive charge move
around, and do these little red
nuclei have to move to do that?
And the answer is
no, they don't.
I can make a positive charge
by getting rid of an electron.
Where did it go?
Don't ask me, you'll
find out in a minute.
But if it were missing,
that would be a hole.
And with that thing in
there it was neutral.
So when I take it out, there
must be a positive charge
there someplace.
It's a little excess
right around in there.
But now I can move
that thing by moving
that electron into that
space and so on and so on.
And you see that the hole can
move but none of the red things
move.
The positive charge
can move too.
That's an electron
and a hole moving.
An exciton is a pair of
those near each other.
How did it get that way?
A photon came in and excited--
that's the fancy word--
the electron.
It used to be there to
make it be in that state.
And it could go back.
And when it goes back, it
would give up the energy
that the light put in.
And that will have
to come out again
either as light, which would
be called fluorescence,
or it could make the
crystal vibrate, or anyway,
that energy's
gotta go someplace.
So what we need to do for
the solar cell to work
is for this exciton thing
to make it to the junction
and separate before it dies.
And so it wanders
around in there.
And then it has a heart attack.
And you'd like the
heart attack not
to happen until it
gets to the interface.
Because if it
recombines, heart attack,
then that energy is wasted.
OK.
So excitons.
Heart attack.
So this is crystalline
silicon or a cartoon of it.
But we're pursuing a
somewhat different strategy
when we make solar cell
materials out of polymers.
And in a slightly hyperbolic
way, it's inspired by nature.
OK.
So plants have
chlorophyll in them.
If there are biologists
here, I apologize for the sin
I'm about to commit in
describing what this does.
So chlorophyll absorbs sunlight
and produces, initially,
something very like an exciton,
a separated electron, a hole
pair, which it then
uses to do chemistry.
It doesn't make electricity,
it makes all the molecules
that plants make
out of water and CO2
and trace minerals in
the water and stuff.
And so what we want to do is
design the beads of the polymer
to be such that they too
can absorb sunlight locally,
that their chemical
locally-- it's
not light chlorophyll
exactly-- but somehow
or other that there's
an exciton that's
part of the structure
of this molecule.
And we can have two
different beads, one of which
maybe prefers the electrons
and one prefers the holes,
like we had the two
flavors of silicon that
make the junctions.
And we're going to do all
this with polymers now.
And so the chemical
structure of this
is how we make it so
that a photon coming in
is tuned to the energy required
to kick the most loosely
bound electron up to the next
most loosely downstate it can
be in, to kick that little bond
thing up to the little round
thing in the previous picture.
And that energy has
to be tuned right
to sunlight, which has a certain
spread of energies in it.
So the nice thing
about polymers is
we've got a lot of
different beads and chemists
know how to make them, also,
that they're stuck together
in a line.
So at least in one dimension,
there's a connection.
Because we need these charges
to move around and get out.
And so it turns out that the
electron cloud along this chain
is nicely connected so that
charges can move around.
If you put a hole on that thing,
it can move back and forth.
If you put an electron on
the thing, it can move.
So this is looking promising.
There's a bad problem though.
One thing that silicon is really
good at that hydrocarbons--
sorry, that the molecules we're
using to make this stuff out of
was not so good at is
making the exciton happy.
And that's called screening.
So now I want to try
to describe screening.
And this will be my, I think,
my last technical slide.
So suppose you have
an isolated charge,
and I just plopped it in there.
And this is not a very
good place for it.
And a way of making this
a slightly better place
is if some of these
electrons around it,
which it repels, remember,
because like-charges repel,
would just get out of
the way a little bit.
Did you see that?
Let me back up and do it again.
They moved out of the way.
When they moved out
of the way, that
makes this region here a little
more positive in some sense.
So roughly speaking,
there's like a little pink
positive-ish place that
this extra charge now
like a little better.
So there's a rather
strained metaphor here
having to do with
people on their own
in a bar, which are like
isolated unscreened charges
somewhat susceptible
to attraction
from opposite signed charges.
But if they're there with their
friends, they're screened.
They're happier in
their local environment
and less susceptible
to attraction
from distant charges.
OK.
So the thing is silicon
is really good at this.
And the polymers, for
rather fundamental reasons,
are not quite as good at it.
And it means that the
excitons tend to die faster.
And this is bad.
So this is a problem
that has to be
solved in order for these
materials to be practical.
And so a way of
solving it, if you
could do it-- so the thin
film of those bluish silicon
solar cells is about as
thick as your fingernail.
And the excitons can wander
around in silicon that far
and find that junction.
But it turns out that you
need to make many, many more
junctions between the stuff that
likes the positive and negative
charges in the polymers to
get the exciton any chance
of finding the interface
before it dies.
And so you need a really,
really fine grading,
10,000 times finer than your
fingernail, to make this work.
Otherwise, the excitons
will have their heart attack
before they ever get to
the junction to separate.
So how do you make really,
really fine stripes
or structures in some
material, way, way finer
than your fingernail?
And the answer is you
teach the molecules
to make it themselves.
So what on earth?
So polymers are
really hard to mix,
different species of polymers.
Because, well you know,
oil and water demix.
But oil and water are very
different in their chemistry.
So you might think, well,
it's easy to mix things,
you just make them
similar to each other.
And indeed, if you want
to try to mix polymers
that's what you do.
But they're long.
And so if there's any little
difference between the two
that makes a polymer
prefer it's own species,
it gets multiplied over the
whole length of the chain
to the point that the driving
force for a whole molecule
to separate is large.
And so it's really
hard to mix polymers.
But if you stick to
dissimilar polymers
together with an
unbreakable joint, you bond
them with the same kind of bond
that holds the beads together,
then they can't do that.
And then what's left of them
is that they can locally
separate into
regions rich in one
and rich in the other species.
And the length scale
of that separation
is set by the size of this
molecule, by the coils,
and they're small.
OK.
So what you tend
to get are layers,
if the two halves of this thing
are symmetrical, equally long
and bulky and stuff like that.
But actually polymer
chemists know
how to make other structures,
all kinds of fancy things,
cylinders of one
kind and the other,
and spheres of one kind
or the other, and so on.
But the point is that the
length scale of these structures
is right around
what we need to have
enough junctions between the
two species for the exciton
to have a chance of getting
there before it dies.
And this is just an
electron micrograph
of a totally unrelated
material, but just
showing that these stripes occur
in a sample that hasn't been
specially prepared in any way,
you just put the polymer down
there and it organizes itself.
This is called self assembly.
OK.
So we didn't have a
big design problem.
We've got a certain
set of goals about what
we need the material to do.
We need the energy, the
exciton to match sunlight.
We need the light to be
absorbed through the film.
We need the excitons to
make it to these junctions.
And we need the
charges to get out.
And that implies because
we have the story about how
the material is behaving,
intermediate properties
that we need to be true,
having to do with this self
assembled structure.
I mean, we need the beads to
have the right exciton energy.
And that, you try to get right
by looking at the chemical
structure.
And there's a chemist, for
example, here at Harvard,
who has been very
influential in pre-screening
a whole bunch of different
beads that you might construct
for whether their energies are
going to be right for sunlight
and also whether they'll
be right for attracting
positive and negative charges.
That's one part of problem
but not the whole problem.
You do this self assembly
trick, as I described.
And then what we've
talked about not very much
is the need to get the
charges out of the sample.
They need to be able to
move relatively freely.
I blithely said, well,
they can move down
the chains pretty well.
You might wonder about
between chains and other sort
of things like that.
So having this
intermediate picture
of what's going on
in the sample you see
helps to focus the
properties of the material
that you need to make this
work without trying to start
from the molecule's structure.
Because there's an
intermediate level of behavior.
So this is a big
project which people
are in the middle of
trying a whole bunch
of different chemicals.
The polymer chemists make them.
Experimenters make
measurements on them.
Engineers make
films and test them
by shining lamps that
look like the sun
and making measurements of how
much electricity comes out.
What am I doing?
Well, none of those things.
I have colleagues
that do those things.
So how can theory help in this?
Well, by making estimates
about whether it's ever
going to work.
By taking the pictures
that I've described
and making quantitative
estimates about, for example,
the properties of the excitons
that you need to be true.
So for instance, I've described
this story where-- so here's
one of these little regions.
And there's the nearest
junction right there.
And I'm an exciton.
And there's no driving
force for me to go there.
So I'm just kind of
wandering around, thermally.
How fast does that happen?
Eventually, I have
a heart attack.
Did I make it to the interface?
So I need to know two things.
I need to know how
fast does it wander?
And how long does it live?
And so the hope is
then to be able to make
estimates based on the
particular molecular structures
of those things to see are
we even in the ballpark?
And which molecules
might work better?
And how much does the
polymer structure,
that straight spaghetti
versus curvy spaghetti,
have to do with any of this?
So I transition now
into the third or fourth
or anyway, n minus first
topic of the talk, which is
what does a theorist do anyway?
So the recipe for the
moving of these charges,
the theory for that is
Schrodinger's Equation,
this quantum mechanics.
Quantum mechanics is
the story of how-- well
a story of how all small
lightweight particles move,
but in this
particular case, it's
the story of how
the electrons move.
So here's Schrodinger.
He was an Austrian physicist
working in the 1920s.
Here's a bust of him at
the University of Vienna,
where he was situated.
It's simple to
write, but there's
a lot of stuff packed
into that H there.
Hard to solve.
The Austrians are
very proud of him.
This is of course before
the EU, but here he
is on the 1,000 shilling note.
He's even on a stamp.
It's nice to see a physicists
get that kind of recognition.
So the Schrodinger equation
is easy to write and hard
to solve.
For us these days,
it's something
you need computers to solve.
And that's not very helpful
to say, what do computers
do anyway to solve an
equation like that?
Well, the Schrodinger
equation, fundamentally
is an equation for how the
electron cloud evolves in time.
So what computers are
really good at doing
is taking a number
and changing it
based on what other numbers
around it are doing.
And so this time
step is discrete.
And the numbers are discrete.
And so the cloud is
a continuous thing
that's everywhere in space.
So what we do,
roughly speaking, is
to make an array of points on
which we represent the cloud.
So at every point
here you'd say,
the cloud is this stronger
or that strong or the other.
And then the computer
updates the cloud
by saying, well, if the cloud
is this strong at this point
and the [INAUDIBLE] are
doing this, then the cloud
changes in the following way.
So that's how you make
the program-- that's
how you make a computer be able
to do a calculation like this.
And people are
very good at this.
It's a really hard problem.
Because it doesn't scale very
well to come back to something
that Phil talked about in
his talk some months ago.
We can solve small quantum
problems pretty well using
modern methods,
but not big ones.
So suppose you're able to
solve some interesting quantum
mechanics problem with a
certain number of atoms
that fit into a box this size.
And then you decide,
that wasn't big enough.
I need a bigger
piece, a bigger sample
to answer some questions.
So you make it twice as big.
Well, right away, that's
eight times as many atoms,
just because it's
three dimensions.
So there's eight cubes in there
when there was one of those.
And you might think,
oh, eight times
is long to run on the
computer, or eight times
as many computers, no problem.
Except it isn't that.
It's 8 times 8 times
8 times as many.
And that's 512 times as
much time or computers.
And that runs away really fast.
So the trouble is that polymer
materials are often disordered,
as we said.
And although you might like
for your chains to be all
lined up in nice crystals, that
actually, they're kind of wormy
looking in at least some
places and this is not really
under our control.
And worse than that
is that, remember
how the electron cloud was nice
and spread out over the chain,
but I do it straight.
There's a little twists and
turns and stuff in here.
And if you twist this thing,
it breaks the connection.
For chemists, it screws
up the conjugation.
So how bad a problem is this?
How twisty are those things?
And how quickly does this break
when you twist it a little bit?
This is the question
you need to ask.
And you need to ask
it a bunch of times
because you want to average over
what's going on in this region
to say how bad is it.
so the problem is that a
charge moving around in here
is going to see not a regular
chain where any place looks
the same as any other
place, but a chain
where the landscape is
constantly changing.
So the analogy
for that is if you
were going to take a wander
in this landscape, that'd
be pretty pleasant.
It's not very hilly.
You can go any which
way you want to go.
A little more challenging
in that landscape.
Quite challenging to go
wandering around in this one.
And a death sentence to go
wandering around in that one.
So the degree of
disorder of the landscape
impedes the motion of you
and also of the charges
that we need to get
out of the sample.
So we want to do an averaging
over the different shapes
that the molecule might make.
And so we just
need a whole bunch
of snapshots of those shapes.
And then we need to do the
quantum mechanics problem
over and over again somehow.
The shapes are
rather easy to get
because Newton's equations
are pretty good for molecules
and they're a lot
cheaper to solve.
And so we can just make movies.
And the snapshots
from the movies
give us different ways that
the chains could be lined up.
And then we have to do quantum
mechanics problem over and over
again on, unfortunately,
a rather big piece.
That brings me to my very last
topic, which will be short.
Coarse graining.
So this is an example of a
recurrent trick in physics.
What do you do when
a problem's to hard?
Well, if you can't solve the
problem, make it simpler.
This is Polya's dictum,
George Polya, a mathematician,
who wrote this audaciously
titled book, How To Solve It.
Doesn't specify.
It's a great book.
It's about the way to think
about solving math problems.
He didn't actually say
that, unfortunately.
What it really says is if
you can't solve a problem,
then there exists an easier
problem you can solve, find it.
But Yogi Berra said, I really
didn't say everything I said.
So anyway, how you make
this problem simpler,
you lower your standards.
So instead of
trying to keep track
of what the cloud
is doing everywhere
in space, around some
really fine grid,
let's just keep track of
whether the electron is
on this ring or that
ring or the other ring.
And then I greatly reduce
the number of numbers
that the computer's
having to keep track of.
And that makes the
problem a lot easier.
And interestingly, the form
of its kind of the same.
Because here, what happens
is a little bit of the cloud
hops from one point to another
depending on nearby points.
And here, a little bit of the
electron hops from one place
to another on the chain.
And so I just lower my standards
about what I need to know.
So down here, the hopping
probability, if you want,
is a fundamental
property of electrons.
Up there, it's got something
to do with the chain
and you need to
know what this is.
And the way you find
out those numbers that
describe this
coarse-grained theory is you
need to solve the same
problem two different ways.
The fancy way and
the simple way.
And so that's done by looking
at a small enough piece
that you can actually do the
real highfalutin Schrodinger
equation on it.
And at the same time,
apply the simpler model
to figure out what it would do.
So here you see is a little
twisted piece of chain,
just a very tiny piece
of a twist, remember,
it's twist we're worried
about breaking the chain.
And it's got these
ends which are awful.
We want it to be
part of the chain.
So we introduce these magical
windows on either side here,
a magic window where
if you go through,
you magically come
out over there.
So you're walking along
the chain, do, do, do, do,
and then you come over here.
And so it looks like
you're on a long chain.
Anybody recognize those?
No.
No fans of-- nobody
has heard of Portal?
Ah, good.
So there's this
marvelous video game
called Portal, which I
encourage you to waste
some days and weeks playing.
It's a first person
nonlethal shooter--
you're supplied this
magical gun which
shoots these two little rings
and makes these portals.
And if you step
through that blue one,
you come out the orange one.
So a man can do this.
It's just periodic
boundary conditions.
So we solved the problem
in the two different ways.
We progressively
twist the chain.
We see how this connection
is progressively breaking.
We compare-- never mind about
the spaghetti of curves--
the fact that these
lines lay on those lines
means things are working.
What comes out of it is how bad
that connection breaking is is
a function of how much I twist.
And then you see if you use
that together with knowing
how twisty the chains
were, you are in a position
to diagnose how bad the
failure of these connections
is in the actual material, which
brings me to the present day.
That is, we've
developed these tools.
We want to apply
them in various ways.
And this is a flavor of
how these tools work.
And so I'm exactly
three minutes over.
So let me conclude
by just reminding you
of the main points
I wanted to make.
I mean, first of all,
solar electric power is not
the only thing to
replace hydrocarbons,
but certainly a key element of
a realistic approach to climate
change.
And it's a huge job,
but one that the world
is very significantly engaged
in to install solar electric
on a meaningful scale.
Polymer based materials,
those upstarts down there,
may offer an attractive
alternative, the silicon.
And the attraction comes
from the advantages
of polymer chemistry
in providing
a very versatile
slate of materials,
and the ease of processing
them once you have them,
and tricks like
self-assembling and so forth.
And materials theory,
such as I practice,
can be a useful guide to
navigate the huge design
space of all those
different molecules
and how you might built them.
And with that, I'll stop
and take any questions.